transformations have long been a staple
in anime I mean what better way to show
off that your characters achieve the
next stage of their power than by
changing their look for me these
transformation are a cut above the rest
either due to the context or the impact
they have in shifting the balance of the
story without further ado let's go
[Music]
we begin the list with the birth of
devil man in devil man crybaby devil man
crybaby starts off with a bang as the
titular anti-heroes born a demonic
possession attempt goes awry as even the
mighty Armand finds himself no match
against the heart and fortitude of a
Kyra this is the birth of a new brand of
hero and it happens with no shortage of
surreal imagery I'd love to say that
this first transformation would set the
bar for the audience as to what kinds of
imagery and animation techniques they
can expect from the series but I find
myself corrected at every term if you
think the first episode has enough
messed up scenes and you haven't seen
anything yet
[Music]
no but you're gonna win ha
don't you don't action
at number nine is Alou cards level zero
release depending on the viewer Alucard
can be a cool and badass vampire or a
living nightmare personified or maybe
even both one of his crowning moments
comes in the unveiling of his level zero
release in this form Alucard releases
millions of his familiars that can
consume the entirety of London the
secret behind level zeros revealed to be
every soul that the vampire had devoured
this is truly a form worthy of being
used for the climax the following fight
between Anderson and Alucard is said to
be the peak of the entire series a
pinnacle of a fight that showcases two
of the strongest characters going at
each other with everything they've got
the fight is epic but I think we'll
leave that discussion for another day
mic guy unleashing the full power of the
eight gates is ironically eighth on the
list
beware the city ones they say a
supposedly powerful character who's been
relegated to the goofy mentor role Rock
Lee's master finally gets his time to
shine in a showdown against mother er
the training gloves come off in this
battle as he pummels the unstoppable
shinobi with the full force of the 8th
gate technique certainly one of the most
impactful transformations in the series
mic guys transformation as he releases
the full power of the dangerous
technique is able to go toe-to-toe with
even Madara despite not being able to
put down the invincible villain the form
at least gets acknowledgment from a
powerful being such as mother er the
form is truly a testament to his
awesomeness and his hidden power that's
been withheld for most of the series
[Music]
at Lucky seven we have luffy's gear
fourth during a battle against
doflamingo Luffy channels his rage
towards the villain and gear fourth
activates to save the day calling the
forum nothing but Luffy appearing bigger
and more intimidating
doflamingo brushes it off before getting
handed a no-holds-barred beat down by
the straw hat pirate now that's a pretty
common scene in Shonen anime but seeing
the smug captain getting his ass handed
to him so handily feels cathartic in a
way in the end it's the King Kong gun
that finally puts an end to doflamingo's
reign of terror shattering his trademark
sunglasses in the process
sixth on the list is mobs transformation
versus Hanazawa who could forget mob
first entering this form after Hanazawa
strangles him the quick beat down
afterwards makes the moment even sweeter
and even more memorable it's a state
that only manifests itself upon
unconsciousness and we can describe it
to be a way of mob unleashing all power
within him at once
mobs eyes turn a hollow shade of white
and sinister aura heralds what's the
Esper's most powerful form in terms of
raw destructive power
[Music]
- the Baba
[Music]
Peter
[Music]
at number five we take a look at super
galaxy gurren lagaan
gurren lagaan has no shortage of
transformations among those forms the
most memorable one in my opinion is the
super galaxy gurren lagaan the war
against the anti spirals is in full
throttle members of teen die Guren
decide to go after the death spiral
machine but they find themselves doing a
terrible job of getting their attacks
past the machine's defenses
it's kitten who rises up to the
challenge and attempts a suicide run at
it
kittens sacrifice isn't in vain as the
destruction of the death spiral machines
completed and the resulting spiral power
gives birth to a new form
you can really study mookaite
angel dinging keep tossing
[Music]
instead a young man Oh Maya
dorita
number four on the list of
transformations is ichigo's complete
holo transformation in Bleach at the
time of this forms appearance
nothing has quite had ichigo's number as
ulquiorra did with Ichigo at death's
doorstep the latent holo awakens from
within him feeding on his desire to
protect and rescue Orihime the holo
takes over giving Ichigo this
intimidating new form in a flash the
tide of battle turns and Ichigo in his
new hollow form makes short work of all
key aura even though selling the
Espada's supposedly all-powerful lance
attack it's an evolution in ichigo's
continuous stream of power-ups but it's
one that seems more reminiscent of those
classic evil forms that the heroes would
rather not tap into if not for this
forms uncontrollable nature it would
have surely come in handy in the
upcoming battles
nothing better than the classics right
who could forget the first time Goku
went super saiyan when even a spirit
bomb wasn't able to put down the mighty
Frieza all hope seems lost to that point
Frieza has been able to overcome and
defeat everyone that's come across his
path including Goku Vegeta piccolo and
Gohan the death of Crillon is the one
moment that ultimately pushes Goku past
his limits and transforms him into it a
thing that Frieza had always feared
nonetheless I doubt that you can argue
that anything can beat this initial Goku
transformation in terms of how impactful
and iconic it was on its debut
[Music]
what Emily
[Music]
at the number two slot we have Gon's
transformation in Hunter hunter gaunt
really been through a lot hasn't he to
say that the Chimaera and art plays a
big part in shifting gone from his
Johnny demeanor in to mentally unstable
would be an understatement
for me what makes this transformation
notable are the circumstances as I said
earlier most shown in hero's power up
and transform in order to overcome that
last hurdle in their quest to protect
those they love not in this case God's
transformation comes in the moment when
he finally concedes that he doesn't feel
anything anymore
the words I don't care of what would
eventually cause his transformation into
a much more powerful form at this point
his battle is no longer about kilowatt
nor is it about kites loss it's all
about the sole purpose of killing Peto
the Mt Logan gives afterwards makes one
of the most captivating and memorable
scenes in the entire series
chorus
[Music]
since dustin sega destiny or our final
top-10 moment is the reveal of the
colossal and armored titans taking a
page out of the book of quotes
who knew that humanity's greatest enemy
was themselves all along such is the
dilemma faced by the characters in
attack on titan upon the revelation that
two of the monsters that have been the
bane of their life for so long the
colossal and the armored Titan are
actually among them midway through the
second season bertolt and Reiner are
revealed to have been working with Annie
for those who can't recall she's the
female type to notoriously responsible
for raising hell
during season ones latter arc it's even
more chilling to have the reveal be told
to us straight up yes Reiner who's been
a big brother figure to the characters
straight up tells Aaron about his and
Burt alts true identity not long before
shifting into two of the most iconic
Titans in the series history it's a
reveal that in some angles came out of
nowhere but that's exactly what makes it
so impactful
ten transformations there which one is
the most impactful for you I'd love to
hear your thoughts so what are you
waiting for your comments are welcome on
which one of the ten transformations is
your favorite I'd also love to hear
about other impactful transformations in
the comments section too for more
content like this hit the like button
subscribe and click the bell button for
notifications of more videos like this
until next time see ya
[Music]
[Music]